Brooks: Do you wanna try a pot sticker?
Do I want to try a potsticker? I'm okay right now.
But thank you, though.
Hi guys!
My name is Grace Helbig, if you did not know, now you know. Your life is different now!
Welcome to the first GraceVember:
F*ck it  Monday! F*ck it Mondays is basically a
sexy and/or sex and/or love type of video. You see the title of this video. I'm going to attempt to do a SEXYYY
fall, pumpkin spice inspired makeup look because ...WHYYYNOTT?
I went on Pinterest and I looked up a bunch of fall inspired makeup looks and here's the deal:
One, I'm genuinley going to try. And two...
*awkward silence*
We don't remember what two was at this point.
Probably a lot like one.
I'm gonna kind of use all of these photos that I've seen on Pintrest and just sort of push them all together into a
vision board for what I'm going to smack onto my face. Though,
I do have an idea that might manifest itself later in this video. We'll see how lazy I get. Let's do IT!
I'm exhausted just I'm trying to explain what this is. Before it starts, Brooks,
do you have something you think about when you think about fall inspired makeup?
Brooks: Pumpkins?
Pumpkin.....Corn?
Brooks: Sure, or I said orange, but corn works.
Oh, you said orange. Orange is also another inspiration, and corn can also be another form of inspiration, because this look might be hard to digest.
I have foundation on my face already.
But I'm gonna put some more foundation on, because this looks way not correct to the color of my arm skin.
Let's balance it out. This hasn't changed anything. This works for me. Oh yeah, that made this look way better.
Somehow I've made my lips look identical to a butt hole, and it wasn't even tryin'.
But maybe that's fall related cause fall means like school starting again.
So like clenched assholes might be an actual thematic element involved. I don't like it.
What was the plan? Eyes! I have this Kylie Jenner eyeshadow palette that I bought last year, and you can tell cause look how gross it is.
Which ones is it called? I don't know because I had my grubby hands. I've scraped up-
This looks like just a herd of grubby toddlers somehow
played football with this. It has all of these very autumnal colors.
So we're gonna try and make our eyes look like pumpkin spiced lattes. We're gonna start out with guess what, just straight up orange.
We're gonna go pretty heavy-handed on this. Wow. Who is she? Unapproachable.
That's what she said. Kind of second guessing that orange as a base coat. Wow.
Basically, I'm just gonna swirl a bunch of colors, and hope for the best.
Let's do now a darker color for the other part of the eye. She's very good at describing makeup tutorials. This one!
Oh, that looks like a garbage fire happened on top of my eyelid.
It doesn't seem to be blending. Neither does a pumpkin spice latte with my digestive system. Yeah, that's like
a camp fire on my eyelid. That'll work. Let's do that over here, too. Why doesn't it look like the Pinterest girls?
Let's blend a neutral color and see if that blends, but wow someone has eyelids. Let's put more orange on. Remember
this is F*ck It
Monday's so we want this to look sexy and make up isn't sexy, unless there's 20 pounds of it on your face.
Let's put some of it, the eyeshadow under our eyes.
Girls do that and that seems right. We want to make it look like we don't sleep, but that's really
SEXYYY.
So it looks a little bit like I have a very sexy disease.
It's not the worst so far. Take this color that looks a little shimmery and try and put it in the middle part.
Oh wow. It did a thing.
Now let's put some black eyeliner on, because black eyeliner is always sexy. Every New Jersey girl grows up learning the black eyeliner is
main
like
foundation of your makeup.
Foundation's not the foundation. Black eyeliner is the foundation. This is how much of my black eyeliner is left, because the Jersey never stops.
Here we go. We're gonna put this on
kind of sloppily and then smudge it in and then maybe put liquid liner over it. Now we'll put it on our waterline.
Ow! Oh wow, there she is. Now we're gonna smudge that in with a brush. Whoa. Cool.
Budget, make it smokey like you're making Thanksgiving dinner
and and you then forgot that the stove was on. Wow, that looks like a very polluted sunset. Okay,
then we're gonna smudge under the eye a little bit. Woah... I don't have fake eyelashes, so: F*ck it!
I'm going to use an eyelash primer and then put mascara over top of it. Every girl turns into Robert DeNiro when they put
any sort of eyelash mascara on.
So if you didn't know what eyelash primer was, it's this white crazy stuff that goes on your eyelashes before you put the actual
mascara on and it's supposed to plump up your eyelashes to give you the illusion that maybe you got falsies on. It's just another way to look...
...really crazy in the process to trying to look hot and attractive.
I want to blend out this eyeshadow a little bit. Now, lets put mascara on. Here we go. Alright.
There's that. Here's the deal, we're gonna do a normal face, meaning
I'm gonna fill my eyebrows in, put some bronzer and blush on, and do my lips. And then we're gonna kick it up a notch.
So let's do our eyebrows normal first. This seems like an eyebrow. Mm-hmm, eyebrows. That's good enough, now lets put some bronzer on.
We're going really hard. That seems like bronzer. Let's put blush on, yay. Okay now
let's do lips. I don't know how to do ombre lips.
But I kind of want to. I have this really dark maroon and this orange. I'm gonna combine them to see what happens because F*ck It.....
...Mondays. Oh God, why does it look like my mouth tilted to the side?
There, that's kind of it. So this is a totally normal, fun,
fall look, inspired by Pinterest fall looks, woah... But let's try and ombre these lips. How do we ombre these lips? Follow up question,
how do you Superman that hoe? I don't want answers to the follow-up, but if you just said orange in the middle...
This is wrong. Oh boy. Is that it? You're right, that's just a different co- color. That's not ombre.
That's just a different color. So this is a fall look that you could stop at and say look how autumnal I am. Whoa, very Pinterest, very Instagram
makeup face model etcetera.
But I wanna push it a step further since eyebrows have been so trendy to f*ck with in terms of makeup and get really inspired
by fall leaves and see what I can make of my eyebrows, but that is my inspiration. I'm taking this brown eyeliner pencil.
*music*
Now let's take our liquid liner go over that. Wow...
Wow, okay now let's fill it in with some orange.
*music*
Whoa...
I honestly
am really F*cking proud of myself this could not be more inspired by...
... fall, and could not be more of a go-to everyday makeup look. It only took me 45 minutes to do this.
Well, there you go. There's my fall autumnal  pumpkin spice pumpkin etc. inspired makeup look.
Let me know what you guys think in the comments down below. If you attempt this, on your own, tag me on Instagram and Twitter
so I can see all of your beautiful
Fall inspired creations. Don't forget to subscribe to this YouTube channel.
I'm sorry, I'm looking at my own self in the viewfinder because I am just
enamored with this. Don't forget to subscribe to this YouTube channel guys, I'm making videos Monday through Friday through the month of Grace-
Vember the greatest hashtag that's ever lived. Other than that, I don't know.
Yeah, you wanna see? Let me know if you think it's fall inspired.
Brooks: Oh my gosh.
Brooks: Whoa...
Brooks: This is a real-
It's a real woah. It takes a second to process.
You're gonna get looked at and the girl that wears this kind of look wants to get looked at.
Brooks: I like that your eyebrows are stems.
Exactly, this is taking wiggle eyebrows up to a new fall seasonal level
Brooks: And this also could be if you like flash...
That's true, so this works for a lot of seasonal events and activities.
Brooks: Or you could go- If you were trying to get banged at a funeral.
Uh-huh, yeah...
Ideally, this is the look that you would wear to a new
uh, significant other's
family member's funeral, like if you haven't ever met their family before and you just want to let them know: I'm gonna make your son
and/or daughter's life different than it was.
This is who you have sex with after you've had your heart broken by the one you love, and you go to the bar
and you're like: You had those tattooed on your eyes. I don't give a f*ck, I'm desperate.
Brooks: Aw, that sounds too personal.
Yeah, I've done that.